[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone how is it going it's
Friday it's not a community Friday
unfortunately and also you've only got
me but we're gonna have a good time
playing the open beta for the division -
I actually didn't get a chance to play
much of it when it was a private beta so
a lot of its gonna kind of be new to me
but I think we're gonna have a good time
we're getting the the count off in the
chat I see I see box Knight crime
everyone's hanging out in here Bob Jones
how's it going guys I'm gonna switch it
over to the game because you don't want
to see me and you don't hear me talk the
whole time
well spoon adjust my volume a bit cuz I
wanna blow anyone's ears out but yeah
we're in it it is it's a Ben Friday and
I feel really bad that John Luke and I
haven't gotten a chance to do much in
the way of like a community Friday
recently there's just been so much going
on a Ben solo stream is not a Star Wars
reference hey it works like wants of
Eric forced you to do this I'm no one
forced me to do it I kind of volunteered
for it because I played a fair amount of
the original division but I I don't know
it it didn't pick up to me so I'm kind
of excited to see what what the second
game kind of does so I'm excited you
must listen to the music the music is
pretty great I was sitting here
listening to it for about 15 minutes
before I even hit go on the stream and
certified bangers all around how do i
download this so if you go to the store
page on PSN scroll down there's a demo
for it I think the same thing on the
Xbox and on PC it should just be on or
not origin the the you play the Ubisoft
a little bit don't want to have that
person talking over me Joey I see you
I'll say your name how how are you doing
how is everyone doing hope you guys all
have some some cool plans coming up for
the weekend
I'm gonna play some some video
probably maybe the division beta but
we'll see
thanks I'm watching this live heck yeah
we're all in this live right now
sponsored by PS I decided to wear my
playstation hat today because it's kind
of cold
it's one of my wor mabini's so
everything is all on brand right now
does it turn used to reckon the division
see I never got too big into like the
dark zone stuff but I know a lot of
other people did I'm trying to get some
some quality time with this the sequel I
like I like that the colors and the
lighting going on right now I'm only
playing on a regular ps4 too though so
not like pro status right now or
anything but it's not looking bad those
are new stuff not in the private beta uh
I heard there might be I'm not entirely
up on it myself but I'm sure there's
probably a post somewhere about that on
gamespot comm you can check it out just
can't wait to leave school and play this
do you feel that there's something I
kind of miss about the the anticipation
you'd get coming home from school on a
Friday to play a new game or beta you
know what I got grenades here don't I
they've got to be they've got to be
around here yeah there we go
to hear that guy take care of that guy
and there's someone else hiding behind a
barrier because of course there is
was everything carried forward from the
closed beta for those who played it or
well it was her like my character wasn't
there so I think that there might have
been a lovely gameplay thanks any time
Ryan I'm glad you're here I'm glad
you're having a good time do you play
the first division to play the second
division I don't think there's any
directs carryover it's a kind of a
different setup than the the original
yeah I think you'll be fine
I also kind of don't remember much about
the story in the division from being
honest it was kind of a blur of running
through a bunch of snowy streets and
picking up a whole bunch of loot trying
to find a better gun which I enjoy kind
of like the the loot grindy type a type
of take on it computer can't load this
game getting pixelated cars and eat more
ram you got to find a way to download
more ram so you can see those cars that
be pixelated I do remember I did do up
to here during the private beta and I
know that you get a piece of common gear
so not a gun unfortunately but we got a
cool mask
oh yeah if you don't need to play the
first beta to play the second I thought
you're talking about the general game
but yeah if you want to try it out this
is your chance we do have a new gun this
is a chance to give the division two ago
and just like me kind of see what's
what's happened with the game we got
some environmental storytelling in the
form of a cool way of communications
device left on that that's a picnic
table how do you like this comparatively
to the anthem beta so far uh I enjoyed
the anthem beta but it kind of also gave
me a good idea what that game was gonna
be like and I kind of I wasn't too hot
on on on anthem I'm not gonna lie but
I'm kind of enjoying this there's a bit
more of like the the grounded kind of
tactical feel that you get from like a
usual Tom Clancy game a lot of cover
jumping around from from place to place
oh we're heading up to the White House
these guys in for an awful surprise are
that guy I guess unfortunately
how's this this new gun treating me
likes yes this is a free open beta for
everyone you can all join in so I guess
kind of in a way this is like a
spiritual community Friday in that we
can all play the beta at the same time
maybe not together play we can all run
around and see what's up with the
division
excuse me these guys so good to see this
yeah I'm glad that we're getting like a
pretty good like demo beta setup oh I've
got some armor to do oh you can kind of
craft new armor plates I like that I'm
into it
oh hello good to see you here so we're
using the same cover that's embarrassing
do you know if there will be a wipe once
the open beta is done I don't know like
factually if there will be but I'm gonna
bet they're not going to carry over
stuff from the beta just because I
usually with betas now we have like
early accesses for things that's
probably behind like an Ultimate Edition
type of setup I'm guessing but I don't
think it'll it'll carry over personally
get to heck hang out here it's community
enough heck yeah
that's that's the spirit gray fox I'm
glad I'm glad you're here and you're
still still having a good time though
there is a part of me that's kind of
like man we could play dead or alive I'm
dead or alive release day with with some
people John look I will find a way to
bring back community Friday bring it
back in a big way and we'll all have fun
together again who are you
get out of here let's get some armor set
up there we go
no crafter you consume it ah I mean I
got sort of to craft is to kind of
consume isn't it cuz you're using
whatever materials consuming them to
craft it I'm assuming
ah we've got some sweet coordinates and
we found our base of operations which is
the capital of the United States
downloading it heck yeah yeah what game
is you guys been playing lately because
I know we got we got like anthem that
her life came out today I'm pretty
excited about that
got division beta going on there's some
there's so much stuff happening around
here I bet we're about to hit a cutscene
it's about time I get introduced to some
characters hello oh heck yeah perfect
closed beta was a lot of fun can't wait
to try out a whole bunch of new features
that were locked at the seams so does
anyone actually know what what features
are different between the two betas cuz
I'm guessing you you might know David
because you seem like you're I trust you
metro I need to get back into Metro
Kingdom Hearts I started three three is
my first game which seems like a really
dumb idea and I know people who play
Kingdom Hearts are like man why are you
doing that to yourself I might actually
go back and put the other two still
going through Red Dead Redemption two
hundred percent by yourself that's a
good call black desert played black
desert a long time apex and Tetris not
hot on Battle Royale that's fair or
you're hot on down royale battle royale
games of course you should go chicken
despicable Sean says in all capital
letters anthem is like destiny there's
some similarities playing out from the
moment and enjoying it for them to know
it's a it's a fun time there's a new
sheriff in town there's a new sheriff in
town
battlefield five and Assassin's Creed
GTA 5 destiny heck yeah I'm playing our
ps4 right now currently
Johnston oh cool we got staff we got XP
just on deck stacked up talk to the
quartermaster downstairs all I hope it
gives me a cool thing
give me some abilities I got skills
we got turrets chem launch your seeker
minds I'm guessing seeker mine's
probably a good choice here bursts are
just regular explosive let's keep it
let's keep it kind of vanilla for now my
branch out a little bit later Greg
Holman hey Ben i watch gamespot vids all
the time this is your first live one I'm
glad you made it Greg and I hope that
this doesn't make you not want to watch
any other live videos later on but I
hope you're enjoying it and I'm glad
that you're here plain udon hey there's
there's so many games in so little time
stream but this this is my this is my
time to to figure out what's up with the
division to I never was great at math
the division - I can't wait for the
expansion the addition to these are my
bad dad jokes I hope you enjoyed them
yes before tea captain marvel to
understand the hate around it yeah I'm
excited for Captain Marvel - I think
it'll be a pretty good side oh god
there's someone looking for backup uh
skill Shawn should be squibs yeah let's
get that why would I not want that and I
think I can actually yeah I got another
skill point okay so that's almost like
that's how they wanted me to do it let's
get a turret let's just go all all
attacking all the time
I need a vacation which throws the best
game ever Dragon Age Origins do I love
The Witcher haven't played Dragon Age
Origins but I didn't reckon Age 2 so
basically I should probably play Dragon
Age Origins I hear it's the one of the
best in the series how do you know the
beta all you do is go to the the store
and download it first time watching
online feeling good heck yeah
I've got level ups happening hit the
streets try space Lords it's a really
solid game I've heard some people
talking about it I'm seating around it's
I'm always down to try games might my
favorite thing about games is kind of
collecting the experiences of playing as
many things as I can so I try to let go
out of my way to play like at least a
little bit of something to kind of like
oh yeah I remember some I'm down to take
that I pet this dog if I can't have this
dog then this game ISM is a waste it's
already running away from me so we're
off to a good start or a bad start I
just want to love you come back please
don't leave me oh my god that dog is so
fast they're already down there all
right well let's not get too far off
track what was the very first game you
streamed live
so my first like actual stream stream
do a quick murder on this guy my first
stream stream that wasn't like a tester
trying to set stuff up might have been
Team Fortress 2 in a weird way because I
the the site that I was working for at
the time was like hey you are always in
our streams playing competitive games
with us and you're usually at like the
top part of the leaderboard you should
do a show for us where you play
competitive games and I'm like ah what
better competitive game to start off
with then Team Fortress 2
so I played that with a bunch of
community members I guess I've always
kind of liked the the community focus
for force training so that works out
yeah Team Fortress 2 and then when I
realized I couldn't keep up a
competitive show because I'm actually
not that great of video games I decided
to just do playthroughs of games that I
like so I can share experiences things
that I like with people that I care
about yeah how's that PS on the beta
seems a little edgy it could just be
because I'm playing on like a launched
ps4 I don't have my hands on a pro at
the moment cuz mine mines at home but
it's it's not 60 I could say that but it
feels like it's around 30 just looking
at it with my eyes but don't quote me on
it because I just see I'm not able to
get like a an actual readout on it but
I'd get behind these signs there's a
good signs heck yeah I was a pro tf2
once the devs oh shoot crime we got to
bring Team Fortress back took community
Friday's with with with Ewan and Team
Fortress and you can show us the the
ways excuse me who are you
we were actually throwing around the
idea of doing like a like a like an
old-school counter-strike 1.6 community
Friday for a long time just because that
game can run on a lot of computers and
we could probably get like a good amount
of people in the office and on it too so
we like we like playing with you guys do
what we also want to kind of give you
guys a chance to like play with us cuz
like me we all like playing video games
like we're not we're not too different
from from you guys you know and having a
chance to just hang out with a bunch of
cool people and play games is always
great uh you guys right here my at my
thoughts about the new Far Cry game we
did do a cool WeChat Aaron John Luke and
I about it might be too early for a new
far cry but like if you like five it's
just more five which is always great but
I enjoyed it a little bit
tf2 Demoman pyro scout sniper with a bow
I'm in heck yeah I think of csgo battle
royale uh it's I can see them jumping on
it for you know wanting to do it and
it's nice that it's just an extra mode
but I I don't think counter-strike
should stick to trying to follow the pad
or I'll try and counter strike should
probably stick to what Counter Strike
does best melee this guy yeah it got oh
we can still close doors it's really the
Division I like it
Age of Empires his favorite game so I've
her age of empires 4 I never really got
into Age of Empires but I can see the
appeal
I see I see what's good about it I'm
also not very like smart when it comes
to like tactical being smart games what
the heck is going on here this shouldn't
be here at all and close that door Oh
reconstruct the sector don't forget that
jarate heck yeah cisco is basically
better anyway oh shoot I haven't been
playing a lot of csgo ID so I don't know
what the current state of it is but that
doesn't sound good
Oh what about halo infinity you know
your boys excited about some halo and
you know that I'm we're 2% gonna play
that on the stream as soon as we can
betas alphas whatever there's a lot of
people in our office that love halo and
a lot of people are actually pretty good
at halo which is really cool they're
just playing it over again cool that
goes you know what is it what do you do
with them show us my time in this
destiny or anthem that's a it's a
difficult question to kind of answer uh
Alex I'd say the first determining thing
wherever all your friends are because
all these games are definitely games
that are better when played with people
you know but if that's not a factor
personally I feel like Destiny's got a
lot more content because it's been out
for a while longer now and I actually
really really like the way that destiny
feels when you play it but I'm also kind
of enjoying this right now like the the
shooting feels alright everything
doesn't feel like
big problem I had with the original game
was everything was kind of bullet spongy
and it's still kind of definitely there
now but doesn't seem like it's as bad
but it's also beginning of the game type
4 Funko pop Gears of War I'll play it
I'll play it if only to say that I've
played it that that might be it it's
still the weird it's like let's take
this really macho meanie like a chainsaw
gun universe and mesh it with these
these vinyl figures that are meant to
like appeal to the most people they
possibly can and just make a game out of
it it's kind of a weird thing
and that that is a good fact that
Sicarius brings up is anthems kind of a
not great game to play with your friends
because you have to constantly tell your
friends to not talk over the story that
happens because there are a lot of
really good small story things but if
they don't know you're doing it they'll
end up talking over it like I am with
these cutscenes right now in this beta I
like it let's do it let's save this this
little girl heard watchdogs is kind of
boring first one not so good second one
I don't know if it's just because I kind
of like the idea of like a Greatest Hits
version of the city I live in but I
enjoyed watchdogs too much more than
first yeah it's it's a good time
over here all these people are just
chillin
whatever I'll just go on to the next
next mission was the name of the
division engine oh I don't remember I
should have paid attention to probably
showed it when I started the game up
watch as I try to like find my way out
of here
and I have no idea where to go even
though I just walked in oh can I drop in
this way oh no that's just helping
someone else who's down there
all right cool I think I've got to go
this way no I'm here to check out I'll
see you later
up there is where I went before down
here now we're doing it do you know the
connections between every Ubisoft game
make a battle royale with all the
characters so that's actually one of the
interesting things that I actually think
about a lot is what games are connected
to what like so for instance Frank West
exists in the left 4 dead universe and
payday exists in the left 4 dead
universe because of that Resident Evil I
think there's something that linked
Resident Evil and in Dead Rising there's
like a like a weird like you can kind of
follow a trail that connects games
because of like actual things they've
done
oh the engine is called snowdrop okay
cool that's kind of a cool cool name for
a game engine though it's kind of sad
that there's no snow this time and your
engines called snowdrop was one of the
best things I think about about there
about the original division was the fact
that it had that really interesting
snow-covered setup ooh
enemy level to find agents yeah we can
mean being a solo this one
right next to the Grand Washington Hotel
okay yeah Frank West is from Dead Rising
but there's like in left for dead there
is a message written on a wall by Frank
West about how he's killed like 53,000
zombies like it's a weird like there's
there's a trail there there was
something that kind of like and it's
interesting I had like a web drawn up at
one point with like all the different
points that connected things but see
that's what I've been saying gray fox
I'm like hey guys look let's do like a
crazy conspiracy theory video where were
like these games are all connected
because like like you were saying almost
every Ubisoft game is put together in
some way it's it's interesting that like
the the theory for watch dogs is that
aiden pearce i believe that was the the
first protagonist name is just an
assassin in like modern time because he
gets like a mission from the it's like
wipe out some templars at one point i
don't use any of my abilities things are
blowing up oh god let's gonna try this
out
there we go
don't you dare shoot those explosives I
swear to god we're trying to connect
Dead Rising with left for dead I think
that might be it it's just that any
nursing thing that I can
most of the case in the sanskrit Susie
an assassin's creed I think is like like
a metaphorical backbone that you could
build almost anything off of just
because of the fact that it spans so
many different time periods and
different kind of like based on real
things
I know Pierce report I I'm still playing
on a regular ps4 but it's it's working
all right it's not not too bad I am
excited to go home and try it on my pro
later tonight because I think I'm gonna
revisit this and maybe see if I can play
with some pals or something but yeah I
do like that they have the like the
Splinter Cell Conviction like moving
from cover to cover very into that oh
wait hold on is that oh you have to mark
it that's good okay I'm back in it
things fine
oh yeah each of the classes gives you
stuff like weapons I've got like kind of
a basic understanding of some of that
which class am I gonna do not not sure
yet I probably want to do some sort of
like support role you know I want to I
want to help people out
whoa people are rude try to get the
flank on this heavy machine gunner what
up do what I see you but you can't see
me and that's real unfortunate see you
later
a good day oh did I just shoot like ammo
in his pocket or something I didn't do
it
although that your hey you know what I'm
glad I'm doing great too Michael
it's good to see you I'm doing better
now that you're here oh and John Nelson
here no John don't don't feel bad you're
good you've got you've got some very
important things that people are gonna
really like seeing it it's important
that you you're able to get that stuff
done well so I know it's it's kind of
nice like I haven't done a solo stream
in a very long time it's not it's not
bad at all we got here and I'm k-16
gimme that
let me see what I got here open up this
inventory give me give me the gun you
gave me the give me the gun it's not
common but that's fine and now I got two
two weapons okay cool cool cool cool
don't deserve John Luke we we all
deserve each other you're fine you're
good yeah it's it's all okay the bad
thing is that people players from other
classes hey yeah that's part of the PvP
experience that's that's just the way it
is you know let's try this uh this new
gun out
hello-o
yeah this is good I'm into it it's more
more PvP now yeah I'm curious if I'll
I'll be into this enough to to get to
the point where I can be competitive in
the dark zone or like actually do some
of that
I'd like to so I really like the idea of
the dark zone
also I just love PvP in MMO types
situations there's something kind of
cool about it I should use my ability
more that mine is real clutch
yeah we were trying to get that that PC
stream of yeah cos are going crime we
were we're trying to figure it out but
it's just so much going on there's so
many things keeping us from from
committing all the crimes that we want
to commit Balak like Michael's saying
both editorial and video of Fame just
there's so much going on all the time
and it's not stopping who are you what
are you where are you going oh hello
let's get some more armor I'm going to
pop this guy out
send him over there I just I like this
so much it didn't kill him
that's okay but till you get the drones
I'm excited for this these abilities are
good I feel like I didn't mess around a
few abilities too much I think I got the
shield and I pretty much stuck with that
almost my entire time playing the
original Game Boy I'm down to I'm gonna
mess around more I'm dying to see what
there is to see it's it's a new game
filled with new possibilities yeah I
didn't work out well for him there melee
eyes is true things that some of these
people are yelling
shoulda stayed away from me I did the
division one I don't think the division
one fail that's that's being a bit
dramatic but I feel like it didn't meet
a lot of people's expectations the
updates that came along later on
apparently did a lot of good good fixing
for it
I'd already moved on at that point but
from what I hear people liked it there
we go get that hipfire good stuff get
some body armor see what I've got it
picked up some new gear - nope that's
just that that's a tone heck yeah new
body armor we got upgrades I'll feel
proficiency - open that up what do we
got we got a backpack and another kind C
heck yeah three through six e damage
yeah let's do it
we're back in it we're alive again
let's go through this door and see who's
on the other side upgrade that javelin
ambos good hit that door I do kind of
like the like close like close quarters
moving inside of like real-world places
like this is kind of cool like I'm into
this I also like the like urban urban
environment combat and games a lot
secure the corridor hmm I'm guessing I
probably have to shoot at them huh this
gun is wild okay who are you oh there
were explosives right there what was I
thinking you get the drone I'll get the
drone next for sure cuz if it's anything
like the mine except it flies I'm into
it oh man oh man yeah Selim
now the headshot sound is it's very
satisfying see did we get it did we do
it we're good
please give me elevator music no hell of
a turn music that's fine it's the beta
there's still a chance for them to put
it in that's okay guys you gonna let the
division - oh I'll give it a go when the
game comes out like I said I like to
collect experiences and I like to kind
of put my hands on everything whenever I
can but god there's so many good games
coming out soon though we got like what
in four days Devil May Cry is happening
or something like that
I suck heroes coming out but have a
really fun time not being good at that
game gotta I'm actually kind of excited
for left alive if only because it's got
the Yoji Shinkawa artwork and it looks
kind of like a weird Metal Gear spin-off
booth there's someone over here that's a
good threat I'm just gonna head on over
this way you're mine
you can try who poops
it's okay I'm gonna whip some shots I'm
gonna do some cool combat rules
everything will be fine yeah
ten shots to kill uh well that's one two
three those three shots it's not not
quite ten this one's one two three yet
still three oh boy I get where you're
coming from this guy is having a real
rough day it's real real beta situation
that's okay
I mean I guess I can kind of buy into
three shots metal gear on normal
difficulty it takes three shots to to
get someone down excuse you
this kneepads all heck yeah now we're
living oh yeah I won't put those
kneepads on slap these bad boys right
onto my knees not much of an improvement
but that's okay we're here for
aesthetics I got to make sure my
character is looking real real good the
enemies have armor I'm willing to buy
into it cuz like you know they're
they're trying to be ready to be shot
like they're the combat ready you know
wait hold on there's an explosive back
there I definitely want to hit that
there we go
yep this is my town this is my corridor
that was my garbage bin who are you
my favorite enemies are the melee ones
that run down the hallways and then run
away when you've realized they're being
shot at oh you've got grenades though
that's okay you can keep it man housing
compared to one ah I think I'm I think
I'm enjoying it a bit more than one just
just off of what I've played so far
during the stream oh god my controls are
messed with because of that grenade
they're making the game easy for me at
the moment see that's how you do it you
got to set up like a like a false sense
of security in the player and then when
they least expected boom everything just
one shots you not not happening yet
souls reminded me of the hotel and yeah
cos are where my demons I'm driving the
truck into it uh yeah I'm into it oh and
no respawn zone this is when it gets
real this is this is what I realize that
I don't know where the door is and
that's why it's a no respawn zone I need
to get a hyena key to open up that hyena
box
I'm there I'm starting to see there's a
there's a connection issue down at the
bottom right what if I just oh wait hold
on it was right there in front of me I'm
a fool but we've got it now your friend
your friend cool all right I'm ready
when you are you've got a cool jacket I
was learning PvP in this game yeah the
PvP is actually a really big focus of it
it's also a unique kind of setup that
isn't in a lot of other games which
might make you appreciate it too but
basically you go into a special zone
where everything's like more
contaminated you can get better loot and
there's like a oh god don't put me on
the wall don't do this to me lady this
is gonna be bad for both of us
that's the drone you know I'm gonna need
one of those get back here it's still
going it's there forever on the student
one of these did I Bank it
I didn't Bank it also they ran away the
headshot
[Music]
hopefully there's at least a stats page
for your character here uh I believe
Jerrica I can check the pause menu I
think there is though like it gives you
like a summary of all your your stats
reviewed if you have on I don't know
what I'm shooting when those guys blow
up but I really like that it happens man
I said this game is a cover based
shooter okay it's a cover based shooter
I messed up this is my mistake deck has
got a giant backpack that guy's got a
giant stick blow him up all right oh
yeah they had like a survival mode that
they added to at one point that'll be
real interesting to see what they do
with it yeah yeah yeah yeah keep it
going
oh sweet Lou that's what I'm here for
oh I got the the tape protective pads
we're here
oh geez you have grenades on their belts
that would explain it
well I nailed them even through the
smoke but I appreciate when when games
do it like ever since Metal Gear Solid 2
I like when games let you shoot like ah
these guys definitely have grenades on
their belts so if you shoot the grenades
they blow up so now it's a nice little
spicy surprise you know kind of kind of
make you stoked whenever you're in the
middle of shooting stuff hold on wait a
minute I have a turret I haven't been
using it it's kind of weird that you
have to equip that yourself by alright
so we've got not necessarily stats there
oh there we got armor health and skill
power and currency down there so there's
some stat readouts and I think if you
look at the gear individually it tells
you yeah skill power health all that so
all that stuff still in the menu I can
open the door it's way too easy
hope the release game isn't this easy it
might be like a beta thing also I think
this is kind of like the beginning or
maybe I'm just that good let's - all
yeah I can imagine myself having a good
time with people I also kind of like
that at least in the original there was
a lot of focus on kind of personalizing
your character and dressing them up with
like different I like the fact that I
could dress my character up in the
division I don't know why I'm trying to
like put more words around it I like
that I could pick my outfit out and look
really cool we've gotten blue drops ah
so I Steve I need to up the difficulty
is what you're telling me I'll see if I
can find a way to do that you probably
did you do that at like the beginning of
the mission in the last game or maybe
it's only unlocked after you go through
it once then see anything pop up put the
private beta so you get to play it in
the open beta
[Music]
you've hit an endgame mission after
beating the first three missions okay
you feelin it see how far we can get
so we're 45 minutes into the stream
right now I might I might actually go
for like the hour and a half you know I
might I might do it I'm feeling I'm
feeling pretty good
hold on yo this is a jam I'm gonna put
this up here for backup
I do like that my tert kind of paints
whatever target that it's looking at so
it helps me kind of find the enemies
that's really good
za got AI good uh I think right now like
the the shooting ones are really good at
kind of moving around the ones that that
do melee like that I mean what can you
really do with melee and I they kind of
like try to move in flank but they end
up also kind of just running into me
what do I get to tell it to shoot at the
door wait I can command it where oh it's
got some some geometry in the way so I
get to actually control and tell it
where to shoot that's kind of cool it's
a lecture
I'm gonna use this and then I'm goin
if that doesn't blow it up I'm gonna use
the big turret at the top that's kind of
cool that that geometry sticks out just
enough to like mess up I should have
used this for the actual fight what was
I thinking
anyway doors down
[Music]
is that my gun that's doing the
electricity hello no it's just some
weird some weird stuff going on how's
the performance on console I'm playing
on a launch day ps4 right now and it's
it's pretty good it's not it's like I
stand before it's definitely not 60 60
FPS or anything but it's it's doing me
alright like I don't feel like I'm
missing shots or anything because I'm
getting FPS drops even though I still
have a connection error because I'm sure
there are a lot of people who are
playing this I don't feel like I'm I'm
lagging out or anything so that's good
yeah it's I still missed the snow this
just looks kind of kind of generic to me
I'd like our chances with meteor to
yeah I was gonna say there haven't been
too many loading screens to like I
pretty much have gotten in and I've just
been going we found it the safe area Oh
I'll accept your mission it's a mission
to literally steal the Declaration of
Independence I hope I hope as soon as we
get it back we get to drop lemon juice
on it and see if there are any secret
messages hold on this might be the best
game ever oh I'm very excited I
definitely do that mission a new roof we
got a barbecue
I'm gonna recruit you maybe hello I'm
Anaya I'm going to be helping out at the
base of operations with equipment yeah
that national treasure life
we're living it use candle crafting
unlocked
except this mission to that mission is
cool confirmed cool Thank You Al Roker
I'm glad that you were here to help me
find the good mission how are you doing
by the way it's been a while okay
talk to the main person thing you know
I'm gonna hang out at the barbecue this
is just just dropped in how's it going
more interesting than anthem so far I
think for me young I'm kind of digging
it more than anthems at the moment
it's I feel like it's it's a good a good
step for for this the series the the
division series that has two games I am
helping just not the way you want me to
trust me there's an easy oh boy I know
but if we fail oh right oh right but we
won't fail unless we come to a no spawn
zone good in this neck of the woods ah
perfect
I'll Roku you're my favorite thank you
thank you she said you did your part I
won't forget it
I won't forget it
kind of bought [ __ ] our new dawn over
anthem I feel like that's a fair room's
fair choice all right we've got missions
on deck cool skill unlocks I have to go
all the way back to the White House to
get my skills I've got some new staff to
recruit got more services crafting
where's the declaration no let's just
let's just pick a mission that's close
to us and just let's just go let's just
go on an adventure
hello there are there microtransactions
if there are I haven't seen anything pop
up in the beta yet but it could just be
that they're not implemented yet al
roker bruton's have a great point
probably for cosmetic boxes because
everyone knows it's all about that that
division fashion life and making sure
you've got the best looking agent you
can possibly have oh it is the second
story mission gotcha
so just follow the the main one find the
agents notes in the safehouse
hit the side mission that we're gonna
we're gonna do we're gonna path our way
around
thank you robot voice for telling me
I've walked out of the safe area that
role is real smooth from very very into
it textures are taking a while to wake
up I guess that's there we go they woke
up we're good bad guys good guys good
guys there's just a lot of trash in the
streets I guess makes sense everything
by playing do events that's fair I'm
sure there's a lot of stuff through that
but I'm also willing to bet they're
probably gonna be like a by Sam Fisher's
outfit from Splinter Cell for your agent
in the division that kind of thing oh
wait hold on I walked right past where I
was supposed to be of course the library
would have bookcases all over the place
outside it was there right in front of
me the whole time I miss Greek yogurt
with honey and granola
you're a bad guy that probably could
have went a lot better not gonna lie
let's put this up here cool cool
not where I wanted to put it exactly but
that's okay you can still see you where
all the bad guys are
I'm reloading if you ever wanted to know
what my current plans are for my combat
strategy its reloading right now
don't shoot me though this is basically
what that man just said and I'm here for
a sniper huh
don't mind if I use my single-shot SMG
to out snipe you I guess
can you one one kill hitch ahead
maybe I'm wondering if it might be a
certain web like a particular weapon
kind of thing like it has to be
headshots with snipers because I'm
pretty sure I hit her in the head not
not a hundred percent play it's possible
okay
I don't know why he's highlighted with
the door but cool storage closet half a
second start loading I'm wondering if
that might I don't know if it's
streaming assets onto I'm a fat it might
be because I'm playing on a launch ps4
there's a lot of a lot of things that
could be in play here but I'm willing to
give it the benefit of the doubt why
would you do that I'm very grateful that
that dumb decision to shoot the
explosive directly in front of me paid
off
yeah
I see you I see you're going around this
way probably shouldn't have done what
I'm doing
you're telling me serious trauma the
screen shaking there we go I wonder drop
this little guy out here and send him on
his way and I can go over here
go are you are you going
hello played launched Xbox and graphics
were just like yours that could could be
a thing here we go it finally got to him
come back here that works 100% plan
exactly what I meant to do there coach
from the other side now roll through the
fire this game has a story it I mean
there's there's a narrative there for
sure but I don't know if it's a big deal
so far it's like ah the White House has
been taken over take it back my
daughter's been kidnapped go save them
find a way up to the roof hmm I wonder
if it's one of these marked elevators
that I have to take it's probably the
case force open
yeah I I got the the pass for for anthem
for 15 bucks play like 30 hours of it
and felt pretty good
like if you're curious about it that's a
very good way to kind of test drive it
but that's if you're curious about it we
should probably look where I'm walking
can I go up more here this is still just
the top never mind
ah broken glass everywhere
dead people also everywhere alive people
found them
alright I'm gonna do this oh I can toss
it I'm gonna put it up here doink what's
that it's a gun sir profits
wait they just like pop some sort of
weird drug thing I feel like something
else is is it work here because it gave
them a green green bar
yo mean my my little turret pal we're
going places there we go now I can send
my my little explosive out that way nope
you go what are you doing oh that's a
big boy
[Music]
to wait for that oh he can move we'd
we'd get somewhere else this is not
working you haven't run into any any
bugs so far on the open beta I had a
couple during a private beta play do you
want to all right so far right now there
we go
it was you that was shooting the whole
time
here come the jams
I'll take this
hit the wrong button in the middle of
combat definitely about to try and equip
this while I'm not supposed to cool put
this little guy out there go do your
thing
if you guys if you if you're not like
interested in and what's what's going on
like you don't you don't have to hang
out I mean less you want to hang out
with me just cuz I'm playing a game
don't blame you but if if you're not
feeling the division you don't have to
be feeling the division that's fine like
I know that for me anthem isn't really
that big of a deal but I know that there
are a lot of people out there who enjoy
it and I'm excited for them and I don't
want to rob them of their enjoyment
they're having and I think it's kind of
a a real real lame move to want to you
know ruin something that someone enjoys
what people have their fun you know
we're all excited to play video games
let people be excited to play video
games when I hang with you not the game
though hey I'll take it and this is a
great time for me to do a promo so get
ready buckle up if you do enjoy hanging
out with me or anyone else at GameSpot
while we play games on our live streams
you should definitely follow the channel
we stream every day 11:00 a.m. Pacific
not every day every weekday at 11 a.m.
Pacific all sorts of things it could be
early gameplay it could be late gameplay
it could be just gameplay because we
like it usually on Fridays it's John
Luke and I playing games with you guys
during community Fridays but this week
has been a heck of a time and John Luke
is literally editing a video as we speak
right now that you guys will probably be
able to enjoy on this channel so I
decided to step up and and do the
division thing so
today is just the division a division
beta hang out with the vendee betas with
Ben we'll get some sort of alliteration
going I hope you look forward to this
new series
is it up again yes now it's up it's open
for everyone to play hoops from the
rafters
yeah John Luke has been working real
hard and you guys it's it's all gonna be
worth it though and at the end of the
day get out of here with your grenades
it's it's a real it's a John Luke
classic jean-luc special here and I it's
video I'm very much looking forward to
watching myself and I'm really stuck
that I got to help make a bit I might I
might show up in the video at some point
so if you do like me just definitely
ways to find more of me and if you're
here for me boy do I apologize this is
wild
go get him out of here
oh it's a named enemy ah goodness
this is looking bleak
[Music]
um yeah there we go get get the fire on
him light them up
shoot them down whoo oh god now I'm on
fires fire looks good on me though it's
real good fire effects see here new
gloves not as good as the ones I have oh
wow the spotlight on me is kind of cool
effect another another cache Hill is
there I like a heel ability cuz as far
as I know you can only repair only
repair stuff there you go that's a
little bit of an upgrade that is not an
upgrade oh yeah so when I just can't
let's put that in that place yeah what
type of game it's kind of like a as much
as I'm not down with seeing like the
looter shooter it's the only way I can
think to describe it it's like a lunar
shooter third-person action game it's
Tom Clancy it's it's it's kind of kind
of what you see in front of you I guess
sure there is a healing drone that
that's a thing I should just get the
drone I should head back to the White
House and pick up the drone I mean
that's what I'll do next so we got like
20 minutes left to hang out well uh well
head past that safe house and see what's
up there and then make our way down to
the White House
the audio cuts out is the audio of my
voice cutting out or the game cutting
out LMG is my favorite weapon in this
game in the sniper dog don't run away
from me don't do it's just like the last
one true there is a sweet parkour button
don't don't don't run away from me I
just caught up to you come back here do
you so fast oh there's some bad boys up
up ahead
oh I can sprint and throw this heck yeah
let's just throw in the middle of him
oink
yeah Adam the dog has got to be fine I
didn't see what happened to him it does
it hurts my soul anytime I can't
befriend or pet dogs and video games too
I feel like we've got another point
where any game that decides to have a
dog should have the option to pet it
let's let's make 2019 the year that we
can pet dogs in every video game you
guys up to looks like it's no good I'm
gonna help my friend out here by missing
every shot that I can time to try out my
new gun what did you do you have a hint
on the video that John Luke made well
John Luke's in the chat I can I can I
don't know if he wants me to like ruin
it
steal his thunder I don't want to do
that but yeah yeah like Red Dead 2 let
me let me pet all these animals maybe
not those rats though I'm okay not
petting their rats
I didn't notice them until just now if
they can dynamically change seasons
it'll make it dope I agree I'm just
gonna walk past whatever that is that
looks or maybe I won't walk past it
maybe maybe curiosity's gonna get the
better of me what do we got here what oh
it's a control point you know what we're
here why not let me just
kind of put that up there yike
[Music]
they're all dizzy they're all days oh my
god
that was wild I'm into it oh there you
johner just just told you you're good
it's the history of Devil May Cry so if
you're excited for DMC 5 coming out next
week
you wanna get caught up figure out
what's going on with DMC it's there for
you it's also 45 minutes long I'm being
told reports say so it's gonna be a good
one to kind of like it's kind of chill
out with like a bowl of cereal and and
have a good watch you know yeah you get
away from it you're the second person
today that's told me it's their town
whose town is it really oh god no I
shouldn't have run into the middle of
this I've made a horrible mistake a
horrible horrible mistake whoo all right
hold on we're gonna we're gonna patch up
here I think we're safe for a second I
need to get that healing drone because
that seems like a very good idea cuz I'm
making I'm making bad plays let's just
send this guy over there
yeah got him
okay so look like the old game it's it's
pretty similar but I'd say there's also
some some differences going I feel like
the game maybe feels better to play
maybe it's just been long enough right I
don't remember exactly but I have a
pretty alright time get back up huh and
I'm gonna say it again - I feel like the
enemies while still being bullets ones
you maybe less bullets spongy or maybe
I'm just better at shooting this time
around on claim control point but I'm
here I'm here to claim it it's mine give
it to me you know maybe I don't want it
maybe I don't need it oh it's probably
just to call their players or this is
just to do this hold on we didn't even
actually start
let me just let me just climb on this
car really quick let me just let me just
do this yes
yes
oh I see him off in the distance with
his heavy armor
oh god hello gadget I think see you
later
I do like this this soundtrack though
look I didn't even notice it before
well friendly NPCs are coming to help me
gotcha what's this uh gun going on over
there what's what's that that all about
oh those are my pals you guys showed up
a little too late it's okay though I
appreciate you
heck yeah yeah I feel that big fan of
the division folk to that death on the
car was a thing
betas being betas you know it's all good
yeah I'm wondering if this will be like
a uh kind of like an assassin's creed
sneer like assassin's creed one was a
really good concept for like what that
game could be and then I feel like two
did a really good job of nailing down
what they wanted to do so maybe maybe
the division two will be a good kind of
scenario like that silver I'm having a
pretty good time just come on around
places and shooting things you know game
looks boring
hey it's not for everyone I mean I'm I
don't know if I'll I'll come back to
this until later on tonight when I'm on
my my pro at home boy they're probably
I'll probably play like Dead or Alive
before I play this cuz I'm really
excited to dig more into that come on
there are a lot of games going on right
now you know I know I know but let me in
Ubisoft this pretty good with second
games I agree al roker rather have
another Splinter Cell him in yeah I'd
really really like a new Splinter Cell a
lot
I like Splinter Cell a lot oh my clans
offline right now but we have a section
of the White House set aside for us sort
of random person say I like making deals
all right I know where we are that's
where I had the thing I gotta go over
here go downstairs and talk to the
person and get these skills gotta get
these skills sorted out this is not
where I need to be one day I'll find my
way downstairs just running around in a
circle
AHA there it is this should be right
over here right over here what up my
dude heard good things about these
drones boy hold on we got fixer drone
allies armor or yeah I'm gonna have to
get this more offensive appearance did
you know your boys about blowing things
up yeah I'll do it our markets are
important especially that's to have a
way to heal myself yet we got we got
people people on staff it's going here
just swap this out get that drone heck
yeah so you have to slow because there's
always YouTube compression and oh look
we got our first regular person YouTube
compression always like the game never
looks as good as it does in person when
you're watching it on YouTube
that's just nature of streaming and I'm
also playing on a launched ps4 so it's I
feel like it's somewhere around 30 fps
like I feel like that's what it what I'm
seeing with my eyes it's fine we're
going we don't need the healer drone and
actually I'm only gonna be out here for
about seven more minutes so I should
probably find something to do really
quick let's hit this side mission they
got a tech cache well clear this mission
out and then that'll probably be it for
the day but thanks for hanging out guys
this is actually the first solo stream
that I've done for for GameSpot which is
really exciting because I used to do it
all the time by myself and now I got a
chance to kind of be like hey I still
got it and you guys have been real nice
so I appreciate that
with the shields though I'll help me oh
let's not get this drona try mess him up
oh just kind of make small explosions I
messed up I'm gonna have to go and get
the proper one can actually shoot
through the glass oh I can't
that's Tyra Lee red okay there there is
something kind of nice about solo
streams top vines big fan of you by the
way
miss vine excited for bite whenever it
happens soul streams are kind of nice
because you can you don't have to worry
too much about like talking over your
co-host but I also really like being
able to like I like being in a room with
with someone just kind of hanging out
look at this door that I can't walk
through think about life a bit move on
the add colors of the vision one there
is more color I do appreciate it
whenever games managed to be more
saturated you know what maybe this isn't
the mission we want to do a 30 FPS is
definitely still playable like I don't
feel like I'm I'm having any trouble
hitting things outside of like my actual
inability to put my cursor onto stuff
but you know shoot the lock oh my gosh
hold on we're going back I didn't even
see the lock I didn't even see it that's
how all over the place I am right now
I'm going back I got this see this this
is why why I like having you guys here
because you you're on top of it and I
can always count on you to help me
realize what I'm what I'm doing there it
is it's right there a fool I am let's
let's do this going in
it's just like Red Dead 2 remember yeah
it's like a history or not find him lux
when you're supposed to find Lux why am
i running everywhere you know you gotta
wonder sometimes so the constant needs I
move forward and try to do things but
it's alright we're in here now this
might be a oh hello there
oh I see what's happening this is okay
never mind I like that thing I like that
thing a lot
I didn't understand when I was doing it
first and now I got it what do you think
about the the gameplay yeah its division
if you like the division you'll probably
like the division too I'm willing to say
that at least based off of the beta but
if you are curious it is open so
everyone can play her right now oh I see
that sniper over there that I left is
still alive yeah
there you go get that repair you run in
there did you run over here the heck did
you go are you kidding me you're already
over on the other side forget it
oh it's downstairs they point a stream
black desert online
I haven't played black desert in a long
time but I mean if if there's a want for
it people are curious
I'd be down to to mess around in it I
think Tay said he's played a bit of it
as well it's a very fun game to play I
realize now that hold on let me just do
this in the middle come back I marked
the other thing I've been looking at it
thinking that it's the objective for
what I'm doing yikes
let's do this really quick
pausing in the middle of all the enemies
coming out was not a good call I'm gonna
say that check this guy out
going over there you go over here
what
see you I like how I can still line up
my shots from I ate my drone all
impressive that you climbed up that
entire side of that may not been the
best thing to heal again know what just
go out there do the thing someone else
still here is this game I wouldn't say
that this game is crap it's I'm having a
good time shooting and moving around and
doing things in it also it's not the
full game so I can't like I can't with
the good conscience like make a call on
it but I'm enjoying playing the beta
just running around soloing stuff right
now
yeah time to check out and time to bring
us in to the end of the stream as soon
as I find the door
I can't jump over that that counter is
too big I have to lewd all these things
though there we go and we'll climb up on
out whoop it wouldn't be a Tom Clancy
game without rappelling oh the bad boys
are here the boys are back in town
go get him oh there I think I just heard
the sound cutting out so sound just cut
out for me there why did I run out from
cover what am I thinking what am I
thinking
yikes I shouldn't be alive and just like
that that's how you mess it up yeah
that's fine
cuz we're three minutes over you had an
extra three bonus minutes of hanging out
and that's pretty alright but uh he did
coke it like food it's lunchtime my
stomach has made multiple weird sounds
this entire time I've been in here and
it's time to go find I don't know what
maybe a sandwich I don't know what I'm
feeling today but thank you guys for
hanging out it's been great I've enjoyed
myself and I hope you've enjoyed
yourself if you did though you should
definitely follow the channel subscribe
we stream every single weekday at 11
a.m. Pacific all sorts of games
nothing's off-limits no rules it's crazy
keep an eye out for John Luke's history
of Devil May Cry that'll be coming up
it's gonna be real good we've got a
whole bunch of like apex stuff going on
keep an eye out for that yeah don't be a
fool stay in school play diamond drop of
play Yakuza see you guys later have a
good rest of your day and weekend this
is weird I'm sitting in the wrong place
for this and I'm gonna have to find
these buttons all by myself
here we go bye
[Music]